great so I'm here to talk about how to
acquire your first million users and in
particular I'm going to talk about the
relationship between your company's
business model in the digital marketing
channels that are available to you so I
practiced law for a little while and I
suppose in keeping with that role I'm
gonna be making an argument here so my
thesis is this your company's success in
digital marketing is primarily
determined by your skill in digital
marketing but rather by your business
model digital marketing is a business
model of competition and the better and
more competitive your revenue model the
more marketing channels that will be
available to you the faster you'll be
able to get to a million users and
beyond so let's see there we go
by way of quick background I graduated
from Yale College in 2005 and I then
went back from law school graduated
there in 2009 and I had no experience or
background in marketing or tech at all
had you told me five years ago that this
is what I'd be doing today I'd have said
you were crazy
we started thumbtack while I was in law
school at Yale there are two dailies in
this photo Jonathan on the right is also
when the founders and he and I were good
buddies on the club soccer team in
undergrad we met Marcos in the center of
the picture after we graduated and we
knew we wanted to start something big we
brainstormed opportunities and we landed
on thumbtack so what is thumbtack
thumbtack helps you hire professionals
to accomplish personal projects that are
central to your life for example you can
use some tag to remodel your home plan
your wedding learn guitar
we've raised a bunch of money from VCS
over time we're a team of 500 in the US
and abroad and we have about as many
paying businesses that use our service
this Yelp or Angie's List and I played
much of our online marketing over time
which is resulted in half a million
business read registrations without
using one salesperson and about 20
million consumer visitors over the last
year this year we'll send about 1.8
billion dollars in business to the
professionals in our network I think
we're now the biggest website where
Americans hire a few different types of
services like DJs personal trainers
photographers and dog trainers for
example so how do we acquire our first
million users well let me first say how
we did not acquire our first million
users we did not have a Field of Dreams
app so what is the Field of Dreams app a
field Dreams app is a site or service
that was built and they came you know
these products these are products that
market themselves for example if your
product involves 14 year olds sexing
each other with messages that disappear
it might go viral and market itself if
you can build it a product that's
amazing for you but most mere mortal
product products require you to do the
marketing and don't do the marketing for
you so we were not Facebook we were not
Twitter and no we were not snapchat we
built it and they did not come
instead our marketing was a true labor
of love
that is we had to build everything from
scratch with dozens of 10% optimizations
over the course of years so if like us
you have a consumer service and is not a
Field of Dreams apps app what do you do
well the first question you need to ask
is do you have a revenue model the types
of marketing that are available to you
fall into one of two categories
depending on your answer to that
question if your answer is no the types
of marketing they're available that are
available to you are things like
scrapping things SEO or search engine
optimization which is the art and
science of making your website appear at
the top of Google's search results or
content marketing if you do have a
revenue model then there are other
channels channels that become available
to you things like SEM or search engine
marketing which is Adwords
Facebook ad display ad mobile downloads
Brandner BAU finance another way to say
this is your revenue model determines
the marketing channels that are
available to you broadly said can you
not have a revenue model you're forced
into the channels on the Left you do
have a revenue model you can start
digging your toes into the channels on
your on the right and on an even more
green in their level the competitiveness
of your business model versus others in
the space will determine the breadth and
depth of your success across the wide
variety of these channels so I'm gonna
be talking about three revenue models
the first is free or no revenue model
this describes the revenue model the
many even most consumer tech startups on
day one then there's good revenue models
I put revenue models here with a pricing
it's crude and not optimized at least
you have a revenue model and most v1
revenue models where the company has
get focused on price optimization fall
into this bucket then there are great
revenue models these are typically
highly optimized pay per transaction or
commission based models imagine big
e-commerce companies uber Airbnb a lot
of the paid mobile app installed world
paper lead models in the lead gen space
at thumbtack we've gone through each of
these three revenue models or we've at
least gone a little bit beyond number
two and the marketing channels available
to us were different at each stage I'm
gonna be talking about each of these
three stages first stage is breed this
described our revenue model and day one
and even describe our revenue model
eighteen months after we started but
after eighteen months
something had happened we'd acquired a
hundred and thirty thousand businesses
who were using her site and we had no
money to do it so how do we do that well
we did that by doing scrappy things so
what are scrapping things those are
things that bigger companies with
revenue models don't focus on unless you
have a business model you must be doing
something that nobody else is doing
otherwise you won't win you can compete
either with dollars or with information
asymmetry and since you have no dollars
at this stage you're only weapon is
information asymmetry so what did we do
well we have a 2-second marketplace and
we need to sign up up the supply and the
demand side we went first after the
supply side and we used cheaper free
online marketing methods to acquire pros
at scale and none of the bigger legacy
players in our industry have dummies why
I think basically because they've had
solid revenue models for a long time and
so could rely on more it
Methos to sign up businesses like sales
we figured out how to do it using online
marketing and we did it at scale I'm not
going to go into too many details we
still use lots of these things but one
clue idea is that we've been extremely
creative over the years building an
enormous team in the Philippines through
oDesk today that team is 400 people so
for every one person working full-time
in SF we have 10 people working
full-time in the Philippines we
literally feel like we've 10 next our
capabilities by building this team
abroad and the team hasn't able to do
lots and lots of manual things that
scale other companies can't even
conceive is possible because it just
takes so much human labour to do it
this team is much of our competitive
advantage some tech wouldn't exist
without them so we spend about a year
figuring out strapping things like how
to scale a desk like crazy they grew the
supply side of our business then we turn
to SEO so let's talk about SEO I think
SEO is a deeply underappreciated
kingmaker in Silicon Valley particularly
among the first time young entrepreneurs
in industries where consumers are
available via SEO SEO builds winners in
these industries those startups that
nail SEO win and those startups to
disregard it do so at their peril if you
wonder how a start-up has achieved slow
steady growth in its product outside of
the Silicon Valley bubble the answer is
probably they focused on SEO and if you
wonder why startup got lots of buzz on
TechCrunch but it never really took off
answer is oftentimes they didn't focus
on SEO many companies became who they
are in large part due to SEO mint
Goodreads Amazon eBay TripAdvisor House
the list goes on and on even today Yelp
still gets 75 percent of its traffic
from
none of these companies really started
until they focused on SEO in earnest so
in our case after we finished our
scrappy phase we spent 18 months
building our site for SEO during those
18 months we focused painstakingly on
the three pillars of the good SEO
strategy which are first building a site
architecture that's easily readable by
Google second building lots of content
that's unique to your website and useful
to your website's visitors and third
getting prudential eyes by the internet
community by acquiring lots of links
that point to your website from
reputable sites around the web this is a
huge bet SEO was a long-term play we
spent at least six months working on SEO
without seeing any results but it's a
bet that paid off handsomely is it my
life's goal to optimize web sites for
search engines no we wanted to be an SEO
company
no but SEO buys us the time and money to
at least have a shot at building a
world-class global consumer brand the
last thing I'll talk about in this
bucket is the content marketing I'd
include content marketing here as well
the last thing Liz touched on it content
marketing is the art and science of
producing and promoting content like
articles or blog posts or anything that
involves writing something that you want
others to read with the goal of building
awareness about your product or service
so that maybe one day people buy it or
use it the question asked here for your
company is is content marketing real
that is can it really deliver the growth
needed to build a huge business when
your revenue model is free I'd argue
that content marketing really needs to
serve SEO purposes in order to make a
huge business impact one-off viral hook
blog posts or even in 99% of the cases
good PR aren't going to build a business
producing content at scale for SEO
purposes might help you build a business
and one company I'll give a shout out to
here is
hello Zillow has built a very well-known
brand
largely on the back of its content
marketing strategy they have proprietary
housing price data and they've leveraged
that data to get in front of the public
and policymakers at enormous scale last
fall they hosted a roundtable with
President Obama on housing policy that
was the result of an extremely well
executed content marketing strategy at
scale over a lengthy period of time in
our case we've done similar things but
in a much lesser scale than they've done
for example we produce surveys the small
business is on our site that have gotten
our company thousands of press mentions
from news outlets governors and
politicians and public policy
organizations over time we did this
basically as a high-end link building
strategy but attack very nice spillover
braiding effects as well this cost us
very little money to execute other than
our time and salary possible so those
are the things that fall in the free
bucket next things and Paul is that good
for not great bucket so if you fall into
this bucket you can start dipping your
toes into paid marketing what do I mean
when I say a good but not great business
model I mean that you have a revenue
model but it's not about plastic so
you're leaving money on the table by not
price differentiation among customers as
well as you possibly could I'm going to
talk about an example specific to our
business in order to illustrate this our
additional revenue model was free
businesses paid join enough to pay
anything to get introduced to customers
after this our first model was a
subscription model so businesses enjoy
our site for free and then pay a monthly
subscription to respond to as many
customers as we introduce it to this
worked quite nicely for a little while
we built the systems we needed to test
paid marketing and we saw that there was
significant opportunity for us and many
of them we made good money at the
beginning but we ran into a wall so
imagine we made fifty dollars in revenue
per month per subscription under that
mountain under that model we could make
a profit so long as our monthly
so that subscriber rate remained under
$50 however as soon as our total cost
including our marketing cost reach $50 a
month we started losing money on that
subscriber higher our ties and cause
rose under us a subscription plan the
less profit we made the more we marketed
the less money we made no matter how
good our digital marketing team was it
ran up against the wall because our
business model was only good and not
great so that's what I mean when I say
that having a good business model can be
good for a while but it only takes you
so far our good business model a lot of
us test
paid marketing channels and not scale
and I'm guessing that you can imagine
some reasonably young companies in your
industry have relatively unoptimized
business models that face similar issue
so we knew we need to change our
business model is something that has
potential to be great that is a business
model that can scale alongside our paid
marketing so what do we do in our case
we ditched the subscription model and
instead or we ditch the spiritual model
instead we switch to a paper
introduction model so how did that model
business have to pay to respond to each
new customer that we brought them and
here's the illustration of how that
worked
see a business take us three dollars for
each new customer that we brought to
them the saint's cost us $2 pretty nice
customer to them we could scale that all
day long
and the more we scale the more money we
make so long as we can keep our marginal
costs including marketing costs under
three dollars per week we could grow all
day long and we did so this is a graph
of monthly unique visitors to our site
since 2009 you can see there's like
years here of wandering in the
wilderness and then we switched from a
subscription model to a paper
introduction model at which point SEM
and other paid acquisition channels
became available to us and we could
scale rapidly in a net in a way that we
never would have been able to when we
were only on subscription since that
time we've been expanding our marketing
to more and more channels and optimizing
our business model behind the scenes to
make us more and more
competitive in those channels so once
you have a great business model you're
off to the races the entire world of
marketing is then open to you to degree
that your business model is competitive
and your success then depends almost
entirely on your execution of the basics
of digital marketing 101 things like any
testing images an ad text so that more
people click on the room and making sure
that the page is not much customers land
when they hit your site are optimized
for them to convert into paying
customers again this is the revenue
world and much of Big E Commerce mobile
app installs and we gentlemen have you
bring highly competitive business model
is the holy grail of paid online
advertising if you have this that you
can start testing across all the
different marketing channels so long as
you have a reasonably optimized final
impression the conversion and there's
likely going to be a good number of
channels that work for you so you can
start with SEM or Adwords and then work
your way up the funnel can do
retargeting Facebook marketing display
ads pre-roll video online radio the list
goes on and we specific to your industry
but if you can go out and bid for clicks
or impressions higher than anyone else
in the market and still make a profit
then you'll be able to calculate your
competitors and own that category if you
monetize better than others on a per
impression basis you win so to summarize
your success in digital marketing is not
primarily dependent on things like how
sophisticated your bidding strategy is
and AdWords or how well you may need
test images on your ads to get people to
click on although that work is very
important at the end of the day digital
marketing this really the business model
competition your revenue model largely
determines the marketing channels that
are available to you and the success
they all have in them so if your early
stage and you don't make money you're
relying on free marketing channels like
SEO content marketing scrappiness
if your business model is good but not
great you may be able to make it work
but you still won't have you'll still
won't be able to win across the whole
suite of digital marketing channels and
if you have the best business model
among your competitor
over the long term you'll be able to win
across the full suite of digital
marketing channels and the more likely
you are to be able to outbid them and
leverage all those channels which will
maybe one day allow you to reach
millions so that's it
all right questions yes
viral accelerator so I would put viral
accelerator straight into the is the
field of dreams [ __ ] it you know by so
they say that the best marketing is
having a great product and that is
absolutely a given and if you build a
great product then hopefully you can get
some of that viral element and some
products are built that are so great
that they only need a viral element but
for us an SMB world there's never well
somebody would don't think of one but I
don't I can't think of an SMB focused
company that has been built with viral
marketing viral points on top of page
yummy so we do pay and there's spillover
effects because people like our product
and come back again and again short and
we're always trying to improve the
product to make that happen more and
more MORE
but while that's all happening in the
background we use paid marketing
channels to accelerate that yeah
totally so I oversimplified a bit and
you're absolutely right I would say that
I would say that that companies in
industries with the best LTV or the
highest LTV can go out and win these
digital marketing channels so you don't
necessarily have to make the most of
money on the first transaction but if
you're making the most money per
customer
over the long term or lifetime then then
you should be able to win those channels
and then that becomes a game of raising
tons and tons and tons and tons of money
so that you can push the LTV out further
and further and further and then you go
pour money into these marketing channels
you lose money unlike the first
transaction and then hopefully you make
it up over time so you're absolutely
right I go for some fun yeah
yeah getting the best revenue model I
mean that's well that varies
dramatically by industry and company of
course for us there well for us it was
like step + iterations stepless
iterations so it was free iterated well
on the non business model but on the
product then step 2 subscription which
was a completely different type of
business model we tried to iterate upon
that for example we rolled out a tiered
subscriptions to try to optimize our
pricing better but even so we found that
that didn't work and then we made this
other step to this completely new
revenue model and we've been optimizing
and repeatedly on top of that and so
there's like - there's you can optimize
the actual price that you're charging
customers which we do and then you can
also build the product behind the scenes
to maximize the LTV and get people to
come back and learn more which helps out
on the back side
it's very tough like every quarter we go
through this strategic planning process
what we're like do we focus on external
growth or do we focus on internal
engagement basically so it's like do you
go out and acquire new customers or you
try to retain the customers you already
have better and it's a it's a it's a
balance and a judgment call you know
almost monthly for us where to put our
design and engineering resources on that
question so I think there's there's no
for us it's almost like okay in either
of those places that we've found
something to kiss we're gonna spend like
the next six or eight weeks just like
throwing all our resource into that and
making that work and then we'll step
back once we've done that and then
what's next yeah
No then over the course of many rounds
of money obtainable so we did a family
and friends round about $500,000 2008
then I'm angel round with 1.2 in 2010
that's when we were on the free model
and then we tested subscriptions and
networked only okay and we went out to
raise our a round and had real trouble
raising it we talked to like 60 VCS and
nobody wanted to its money and then we
switched to the paper lead model as we
thought that we might not get funding
and we might die and so we were like oh
crap we need to make money let's switch
the revenue model and Dan we got money
and then we just been like iterating on
that since then all right thank you am I
done
all right thank you